a lot of athletes have this term around
the a game and showing up and doing
their absolute best mentally emotionally
physically spiritually etc and it got me
thinking about do you even know what
your a game is do you know what your a
game is like what has to happen in order
for you to be at your best to play at
your best is it a routine is it a diet
is it a way of thinking is it planning
what is it that would cause you to play
your a game and so here's just a little
maybe task for you to consider take 10
minutes and ask yourself this question
in order for me to play to be at my best
here are the things that need to happen
and just make a list of what are the
things that need to happen i know for me
for example i have routines i have
routines in the morning i've grab
routines in the evening and my routines
give me the best opportunity to feel my
best and to do the things that are gonna
give me the greatest results that i want
and so i've discovered that most people
never think of this and so that's your
task for today is what has to happen in
order for you to have a great day and
create a list for one great day what has
to happen in the morning in the
afternoon and the evening so think about
thoughts emotions feelings and behaviors
and also think about exercise diet and
nutrition think about meditation think
about anything that could help you have
an a game day and then go and do it need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and i
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
john ashraf and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two create a plan hey there
great day to you i was just talking to a
friend of mine in london while i was
doing a little bit of a workout this
morning here at the house
and
it dawned on me to ask you this question
because i asked him this
i said how's your health plan working
how is your income producing plan
working
how is your
managing your budget working plan how is
your spiritual
awareness plan working how is your
business growth plan working how is your
career enhancement plan working
and he shared with me that uh
he doesn't have a plan
and this is a dear friend i've known for
a while
and so i said without a plan what do you
expect to happen
and obviously he got the point
but it also made me aware
one of the things that i just learned
how to do
that i think
is a key factor in my success is for
whatever goal i want to achieve i create
a plan it doesn't matter how
simple it is it doesn't have to be
complex but
i create a plan uh here's what i'm going
to do
or here's the goal right and the vision
of the outcome of that goal and how it
feels and looks and
who i'm impacting and how it's going to
make me feel
and then i just set a really simple plan
to get it started what am i going to do
on monday tuesday wednesday thursday
friday saturday sunday
put into my calendar and just do it uh
it doesn't have to be that difficult but
in the absence of a plan
um then there's too many variables that
can
get in the way it's like you know being
on a
on a boat over here and you want to go
you know somewhere
you know like hawaii which is about
eight hours that way you don't have a
plan of where you're going to be in a
day
in two days and three hours so
ask yourself what's your plan
why not put together just a simple plan
for inner sizing to strengthen your
mindset your emotional skills your focus
your awareness
put a plan together for
the actions required
to achieve your goals
and just start but be consistent right
consistency is one of the keys to
success rule number three control your
journey over the last couple of weeks as
i've been in a lot of self-reflection
mode
reviewing what worked in 2019 what
didn't
and why
um and as i looked at the person in the
mirror who is responsible for what
worked and what didn't
here's what i can share with you were a
few of the key distinctions and lessons
for me
number one is details matter
the
goals that i had in 2019
where i was
really clear on the outcome
and
the specifics of how i was going to
achieve it
and i built into my calendar
the review process to see whether i'm on
track or off track and to determine why
when i looked at the results that i
achieved
every single goal that i achieved was
backed by the strategies the tactics the
timelines the tools and the resources to
achieve that goal
and every single goal
that i didn't achieve
did not have the strategies the tactics
the timelines the tools and resources to
achieve it
so what does that tell me that i can
impart and share with you
number one a goal without
a clear plan
is really not enough to make it happen
and so what i've been doing for the last
two weeks for my own personal goals for
the goals with my wife
for the goals with my team for neurogym
is we have been breaking down every goal
that we are committed to achieving not
that we want to achieve that we are
committed to achieving
and we are drilling down
with exactly how we're going to achieve
it
and
here's what is really critical
i have a theme and that's around
slow is smooth and smooth is fast let me
explain
i tend to go fast let's go come on let's
go go come on come on come on
and for some things that works and for
other things
it just doesn't work and so i am going
to be working on
focusing on
slowing down
to get all the plans systems processes
in place
so that we can actually pick up speed
instead of let's go and figure it out
along the way
so for you
why not maybe adopt you know my theme
for at least a month slow down to pick
up speed and take every one of your
goals for
this quarter
and slow down enough to ask yourself how
am i going to achieve that goal whether
it's a health goal relationship goal
career goal business goal financial goal
how are you going to do it
and come up with your plan and it
doesn't matter if your plan is you know
simple or complex but come up with your
plan and then take that plan and put it
into your calendar and then work
your plan every day every week every
month every quarter
and then adjust on a regular basis many
of you know that i take about 15 to 20
minutes every morning to look at my plan
for the day my appointments for the day
the outcomes for the day i take about 20
to 30 minutes every sunday night to
review my week
and to plan the following week i take
about two to three hours every month to
review the month
and then i take a day every quarter to
review the quarter
why
well imagine that we were on a you know
on a boat on the water over there we
were going from here in san diego let's
say we were going to the south pacific
islands we'd pick our destination and
then we would check are we on track or
are we off track on a regular basis and
maybe there's a gps system on the boat
that tells us you know you're you're
heading in the right direction or you're
not heading the right direction making
some auto corrections but there's also
the pi of the captain right making
adjustments based on the the wind the
temperature of the water the waves etc
so why not become the captain of your
own ship with your destination
the points you're going to achieve along
the way and a bunch of points in between
the check and balance check and balance
check and balance check and balance the
more frequently you check and balance
are you on track or off track doing the
right things or not
the
more you can predict whether you're
going to achieve your goals and dreams
rule number four learn to adapt first
and foremost you know i like to deal
with reality of what is going on and
what is the truth first and foremost now
let me ask you a question
would you agree
that
times of uncertainty
times maybe a fear for some people times
of stress for some people
is also a time for us to learn how to
adapt
isn't adaptation one of the greatest
skills okay
that we as humans can learn and
many years ago when i was in the
galapagos islands
i bought a hat and if you have ever been
to the galapagos you'll know that it's
like going back five million years and
there's a saying there and i got this
hat says adapt or die why because the
survival of the fittest
okay the whole idea of survival of the
fittest is based on darwin's work and we
actually retraced his trail with uh with
the beagle when he was writing about the
survival of the fittest and learning
about adaptation is the animals that
learned to adapt were the ones that
survived the ones that got to survive
obviously multiplied so here is my
question for you okay
we are sometimes the most advanced
species on earth uh most intelligent and
i'm gonna say sometimes right what are
you doing to adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt right now
what are you doing to adapt mentally
what are you doing to adapt emotionally
what are you doing to adapt physically
what are you doing to adapt spiritually
what are you doing to adapt financially
right those are the five places of
adaptation right so spiritually
emotionally mentally physically
financially so what are you doing okay
to adapt
right what are you doing to adapt
when there are things happening in our
environment
whose responsibility is it to adapt
right so let me share something with you
if it's true that
adaptation is a skill
right if it's true that you know as a
human species we have the ability to
adapt let me give you a couple of things
that may help okay and i like that
praying yeah um share with me you know
what you're doing diverging i guess you
didn't like my comments because you're
still here right so share with me how do
you
manage let's start with number one how
do you manage your mindset
to go from being reactive
to being responsive is that something
that every one of us can do
when we're
reacting
it's usually without any thought
right it's usually without any thought
when we're responding it's usually
because of thought
right and i don't mean just thoughts i
mean thinking so the way i like to do it
is say here's what's happening whether
it's you know interest rates uh the
market crashing covert monkey pox uh the
texas shooting which please you know
let's say some prayers to all of the
families all of the families um you know
that are going through this nightmare
right now
but what can
we do what you and i can do
to respond instead of react
right so naturally depending on the
situation we may react in anger
um and that's that's a part of our fight
flight response right we're gonna act
out of anger and blame and shame and
guilt
that's right but we may act in a state
of fear right fear is a protective state
since the number one priority of our
brain
is to avoid any uh pain or discomfort
but also to
make sure that anything that is
happening around us
right um is
managed for survival and safety survival
and safety
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five have discipline every
one of us is 100
self-disciplined already to our current
thought patterns emotional patterns and
behavioral patterns which obviously are
responsible for our results so
my question for you today is this
do you have the right disciplines
do you have the right disciplines to set
goals create plans and achieve them do
you have the right disciplines to prime
your brain
with your vision your goals and your
plans for the day every day do you have
the right discipline to review
your day at the end of the day to see
what did you do well what could be
tweaked so that tomorrow is even better
do you take time on sunday nights for
maybe 30 or 40 minutes to plan your week
so that you're not reacting to stuff but
you're planned you're organized you're
in action that's deliberate versus
reactive that's another discipline
do you take time every month to review
your month do you take time every
quarter to review your quarter do you
take time at the end of each year to
review the whole year and then to plan
your vision for the next year your goals
for the next year now
these little disciplines
are what i call keystone disciplines or
keystone
behaviors and habits that set you up for
success and so
i like to consistently ask myself
do i have the right keystone habits the
the big things you know that swing the
little hinges that swing the big doors
so a couple things i can tell you that
really work for me
is taking the time to think to plan
to
review my results
and in
a state of no blaming myself no shaming
myself no feeling guilty no justifying
no wishing i wish it was different or
better or this or that just in a pure
state of awareness
i tweak and adjust and tweak and adjust
and tweak and adjust and tweak and
adjust
and here's what happens what you'll
discover is you're gonna be on course a
lot of the time
you're to be off course some of the time
but when you take the time to recognize
if your thoughts are aligned with your
vision and your goals are your emotions
your your things that cause you to take
action and not align with your vision
and goals are the behaviors that you're
taking aligned with achieving those
goals now
when you're in a constant state
of review tweak adjust behave review
tweak adjust behave
that is a self-disciplined
action and habit
that will lead you to achieve every one
of your health wealth relationships
career business charitable
every goal you have
the how to achieve the goal
is the easiest part getting yourself to
take the inspired action because you
have a big reason why you must
is really what you need to work on
because we all are gonna have challenges
we're gonna have failures we're gonna
have days we feel like on top of the
world and other days we feel like oh man
i just don't even feel like getting out
of bed that's okay that's normal that's
called being human
but if you have the self-discipline to
get up and do
a little bit to get up and adjust and
tweak
then you win the game more than you lose
the game uh think about
athletics for just a moment
to make it into the hall of fame for
exactly for example in baseball
you will not hit
three out of ten balls
you will not hit him you will not get on
base that means you're failing so to
speak seven out of ten times but to make
it to the hall of fame the best of the
best all you need to do is
hit get on base three times so a lot of
people have a misunderstanding of
success and that is that you succeed
every single minute every single hour
every single day and that's not just not
true
right uh the most successful people in
the world are consistently
taking action
making sure that it's the right action
if it's not they adjust so
have the self-discipline
to
not blame shame justify or make yourself
feel guilty have the self-discipline to
create the plans take inspired action
manage your thoughts get into the right
state the physiology the feelings that
you need in order to achieve your goals
dreams take inspired action daily and
don't focus on perfection focus on a
little bit of progress every single day
rule number six develop good habits
every one of us has got commitments
whether it's commitments to our family
our friends our children our boss our
employees
our parents our siblings we all have so
many commitments
in every area of our lives health wealth
relationships career business fun
experiences charity
and
how are we supposed to
manage all of it
and the answer is very carefully
one of the only ways that i have learned
how to manage the complexities of life
is to compartmentalize the different
areas of life and to set up a process
of prioritization based on the highest
values and the uh doing the things
that
have to get done before any of the other
things
now the reason i bring this up is harry
who i just had
lunch with as i mentioned he was sharing
with me that one of the things that
helped him last year was that i gave him
this framework to be able to manage some
of the complexities that were happening
in his very very
successful and busy life
and the
framework i gave him was to take each
area of his life and either create you
know a sheet of paper that he can write
on
a whiteboard that he could write on or
even on your computer and ask yourself
in the area of your whether it's
spiritual health
what is one thing that you can do if
that's important to you
every day or every week to make sure
that you can get that done
in the area of your emotional health and
well-being what's one thing that you
want to get done in the area of your
mindset what's one thing you can get
done in the area of your physical body
what's one thing
that you can get done either every day
or every week or every month depending
on
what it is that you want to achieve and
then you do the exact same thing
for your business
there aren't 500 different things that
you and i have to do when we focus on
the one thing
in each area of our life and we get that
one thing done
then we're making progress we're moving
the needle down the field now in some
areas of your life of course there's
going to be two or three things but when
you get it out of your head and on to
something that you can look at you get
rid of the neural overwhelm and the
emotional
anxiety that comes by having so many
things that you're trying to think
through in your brain so most people
i've found
they don't take any time to plan
their health wealth relationships career
business and they have no order to what
they need to do what they must do
and by when
and so when you structure your uh your
behaviors
from highest importance
to lowest you'll see that some of the
lowest imp things that need to get done
aren't the most impactful they're not
the ones that move the needle
now it just takes a little bit of time
to sit to sit stop what you're doing
sit
think a little bit
create some lists for health
wealth relationship career
business fun and experiences and charity
there's your seven categories
and then
itemize the stuff that you want to get
done
give yourself
the
gift of discipline give yourself the
gift of structure give yourself the gift
of thinking before you act
and then tweak and adjust on a daily or
weekly basis and i promise you
you will become so much more effective
you'll reduce your stress you'll reduce
your anxiety you'll increase your
productivity
and chances are you're gonna increase
being happier and achieve more of your
goals rule number seven take care of
your well-being i was just thinking
about
the amount of stress that each one of us
has on a day-to-day week-by-week basis
and i know that we're all focusing on
achieving our goals health goals wealth
goals relationship career business fun
experiences
and one of our
health goals
should also be you know well-being
and so my question for you is do you
have a well-being
plan
now
i have a lot of stress in my life
mostly business related just the amount
of work that i want to get done the
goals i want to achieve
and the company that i want to build and
so i work a lot of hours
even when i'm on vacation like i am
right now
i'm thinking about business i'm thinking
about a lot of different things and what
i can share with you for me that works
for me is i also have a wellness plan
that includes
you know proper eating proper sleep
proper
nutrients in the form of vitamins
minerals etc
i also have a exercise regiment a
meditation regiment a vacation plan as
well now
all this may sound like a lot of
planning
and the truth is
when you take the time to think about
how do you get yourself in the best
mental emotional
spiritual and physical health
so that you can achieve all of the goals
that you have
with all the stress of learning new
things of making mistakes of things not
working out
and the only way to do that is you have
to step back sometimes
and allow yourself to rejuvenate first
so that you can actually think about
the goals you have but also the plans to
achieve them
so
i like to get to my home here in
telluride colorado and ski several times
during the you know winter season and
several times in the summer season i
like to travel a lot
and what i find for me is that it
rejuvenates me at every level of the
game
now you may be thinking well i can't
afford to take the time off and the
truth is you can't afford not to one of
my dear friends dr barnett meltzer once
said
if you don't make time for your health
your illness will make time for you
and so in this world of massive amounts
of social media people pulling for our
attention online and offline in our
families and our own you know gyrations
of what goes on into our heads
you have to figure out what is my
wellness plan
so that i could be and feel well
and in the absence of a plan there's
going to be stress and when there's a
lot of stress
then there's no time to rejuvenate
and what i find for myself is when i
allow myself to get too stressed
then the easy things are hard and the
hard things feel nearly impossible
and so this is my
plea to you
to come up with some time where you can
take half a day off just to focus on you
get off of technology get off of tv get
off of radio get off of
social media and focus on your health
and well being rule number eight unleash
your full potential and whenever i ski i
get these
bursts of inspiration
and that's part of actually not being
focused on work
actually allows your imagination and
creativity to
i guess filter through and i had this
thought
that i want to share with you
around one of the greatest lessons i
learned and i've shared this before with
many of my students in my exceptional
life coaching program
and that is this
you can set your goals
based on your current level of skills
your current level of knowledge
your
you know circumstances conditions
or
you can set your goals based on
what you want to achieve
and then figure out what skills do you
need what knowledge do you need
what help do you need what beliefs do
you need
in order to achieve those goals and in
essence
setting your goals based on current
circumstances
is
a limited way of doing it in my opinion
when i know that you and i have
you know a hundred billion dollar brain
that can go to work to figure out
how to achieve almost anything
and so as we you know get into a new
year
i want you to ask yourself some
questions
are you training your life for what you
love are you living the lifestyle of
your dreams
or is there a dream life you would
really love to live how healthy would
you love to be how much income would you
love to make
how much charity would you love to give
how would your relationships be if they
were just the way you wanted them
and why not start with what you really
really really want and don't allow
yourself
to
you know look at your present
circumstances or what's happening in the
world right now but instead go and
create the circumstances
internally and externally to achieve
your goals and dreams give that a shot
what i can promise you
is by focusing on what you want
and being creative and using your
spiritual genius using your emotional
management techniques that you can
upgrade using your
ability to stay focused and more aware
to get this physical body of yours into
action
you'll be able to achieve more of your
goals and dreams and if you set your
goals based on your current
circumstances or conditions
don't settle for less
go for gold
go for being the best version of
yourself and become all that you're
capable of becoming rule number nine
invest in your present a few years ago i
met a guy by the name of dr david
krueger and he's a psychiatrist and he
and i were talking about
stories that we have everybody has a
story we have a money story we teach
about winning the game we teach about
your money story in the winning game of
money program and how to reprogram your
brain for a stronger money story and we
have a story around our health our
relationships our career our businesses
we have a story about everything
and then we go about living that story
over and over and over again and very
few people think about the fact that we
are repeating
the same patterns in many cases of our
parents or even of our own lives from
the time we are 20 30 40 50 60. well
what if you can go to the future
and you can think about if i could
change my story today that would get me
to the future that i want what would the
story say
and in the book
i've given you some inner sizes and some
exercises to start writing out your
story now you may think what do you mean
write out my story
i learned many years ago to write out
my money story my life story my
relationship story and i've always
started in this fashion i'm so happy and
grateful for the fact that
i am living the life of my dreams and i
am traveling all over the world first
class and i am able to give to the
charities that my wife and i and
children love and i'm able to and i
write down in present tense
everything that i'm doing feeling
experiencing for health wealth
relationships career business finances
fun experiences charity i write down a
page or two pages that is a story
that i want my future to be like
and then
i type it out
so i usually write by hand i type it out
and then i laminate it then i'll record
it
and then i'll listen to it over and over
and over again now you may think
that sounds silly why would you do that
why
because any information that you get in
through the senses through your ears
through your eyes that you touch that
you feel
activates neurons in the brain
when those neurons are activated and
they wire together if you repeat it
often enough
your brain says hey
you're investing a lot of time and
energy on this stuff
let me start to put some automatic
processes to make that story real
and this is where
winning
from the inside out comes to play this
is why using meditation and
visualization and mindfulness and
affirmations and emotional
emotional management techniques and
subliminal programming all work if you
can get the information into the brain
and you have spaced repetition backed
with emotion
you are going to develop the neural
patterns that will activate
something called automaticity
all right or automaticity is when these
neurons activate automatically and then
your perspective changes your beliefs
start to change your behavior starts to
change the filters by which you see the
world and the lens by which you see the
world start to match up
with the story one of the first things
we do in our way the game of money
program is we help people program a new
money story so they can then earn the
money they want and live the life of
their dreams animal number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is
believe i remember
25 years ago when my first son was born
in
may of 1995 i felt this incredible
gift that was being given to me
and something weird happened
i went to the bathroom when my
wife's water broke and i showered and i
scrubbed myself
you know from head to toe with a brush
and the thinking that was going on in my
head at the time was
for the last let's say nine months or so
this unborn child was in my uh wife's
belly
and
whatever was happening this intelligence
and and you know nature doing its thing
i was about to get this gift and i
remember thinking
and i'm not religious just so you know
thinking that god was giving me this
gift right and um this miracle this just
incredible
thing called a baby and i remember
feeling
extremely emotional
my life was about to change
and it certainly did i have been
so so so grateful and blessed and
involved every day in the life of my
son keenan who was born 25 years ago and
my son noah who was born 23 years ago
and the purpose of this specific video
i wanna just
focus for just a moment on life
have you really ever given some thought
to what it took what it takes to to give
and sustain life so if we reverse back
you know
your life
uh for however many years you've been
born to the day you were born and
reversed back around 285 days from when
your mother and father had sex
and the sperm and the egg connected and
the x chromosomes and the y chromosomes
uh interlocked and multiplied 26 times
until you were born
have you ever considered
the billions of years of evolution to
make that happen the
perfection
of that happening many years ago when i
wrote one of my books
i likened life happening to a printing
press imagine
if you are
standing outside of a printing press you
know a company or a building that that
produces books or newspapers
and imagine that in this printing press
or this printing
business there's ink there's paper
there's letters you know the little
letters that you stamp onto things
there's everything that's needed to make
a newspaper or to you know to print a
book
and imagine that this printing
business explodes
and all of a sudden somehow by
miracle it all comes together and then a
book lands
you know on the table right next to you
or on the floor right next to you
the idea of that happening is crazy
right
well
the miracle that you are
is crazy right it's just oh my god what
an incredible miracle you are
that i am that we are
and so today i wanted to just remind you
of the intelligence
that created you the intelligence that
is within you that you are
so
feeling less than
feeling like you're not good enough
feeling like you're not smart enough
feeling like you're not worthy enough
really
you are a miracle of life you are a
miracle of creation
within you
the hydrogen the oxygen the nitrogen the
carbon and all the other elements the
atoms and the molecules that make you
you
is nature's perfection
yes with all of our flaws and
idiosyncrasies and challenges and and
things we do great and things we don't
that's the miracle of you you are unique
only one of a kind you're not supposed
to be like anybody else
you're not supposed to feel better than
or worse than less than
anybody else
equal
every day
every minute
every hour every month every year
you are a miracle
why not
act that way
why not feel the miracle that you are
why not be
express love give share understand be
compassionate be empathetic
to another human being
who is a miracle
and take a look all around you
because life is a miracle
albert einstein said you can either live
your life as if everything is a miracle
or nothing is a miracle
well today i want to let you know
you
are a miracle
at the end of
your day or week do you ever find
yourself
worried or frustrated because
no matter how much effort
you put in to work and no matter how
hard you work
your financial situation
and your financial future may never seem
to be improving you might be finding
yourself living paycheck to paycheck
right now with not a lot of breathing
room and i would imagine no
discretionary income or even time to
spend on the little things that really
would make your life more enjoyable
well what i can share with you is you're
not alone that's number one and in most
cases
the real problem is not your current
circumstances
what the real problem is that most
people repeat the same
patterns of thought
and behaviors over and over again
and that is the cause
of what
more of the same results but they are
looking for different results and so
today i'm going to show you how to break
that pattern break that cycle
now you see when you think of your
results your results are effects and so
the question is effects of what
and the answer is your results are all
effects of what you believe to be true
about yourself what you believe to be
true that is possible
and it also comes down to what are your
daily habits now
if you think about what you believe and
if you think about your habits that is
what is causing the effect that you may
not like right now and so a simple
logical thing to do would be to
understand that if i could change my
beliefs about what was possible and what
was possible for me specifically and i
could create more empowering habits then
my result will change
and what i love to focus on having done
an enormous amount of brain research
over the last 10 years
is something called your inner game
and your inner game
is comprised of obviously your beliefs
your attitude your perceptions how you
see the world
and your inner game is also comprised of
what causes you to take action
and so let me share just a little story
with you that may help you understand
what i mean
about two years ago i was at a seminar
and when i got off the stage this woman
started walking towards me and i could
see she was somewhere in her you know
50s maybe early 60s she looked nice she
was a vibrant woman she was walking
right towards me and i saw tears
streaming down her eyes
and when she got through the crowd
for a moment i thought that maybe there
was something wrong but she actually had
tears of joy in her eyes
and when i met her her name was joni
sanderson and this was in perth
australia and she came up to me she said
thank you so much and i go well for what
she says well
about a year ago i heard you speak about
beliefs
and habits and mastering my emotions and
really working on my self-worth
and she said to me that she was a
caregiver and that she loved helping
families who needed
extra assistance for their aging parents
or for their children who may need some
additional help in the home so she was a
wonderful caregiver but she was living
on a widow's pension of about 12 000
aussie dollars a year and so she really
didn't have enough money to be able to
take the care of her grandkids that she
wanted to to be able to take her
children on a vacation and so i shared
with her why do you think that you're
only earning twelve thousand dollars a
year and she said i don't know and when
i shared with her that she possibly
believed that that's what she was worth
and she said to me well i think i'm
worth more i said well you might be able
to declare that you're worth more but if
at a deeper level
of your brain
you have this feeling that maybe you're
not smart enough or not good enough or
not worthy enough
that is what is going to drive your
behavior
and so what i helped joanie do prior to
her coming to me and being in gratitude
was i helped her recognize that beliefs
drive behavior beliefs drive emotions
habits drive behavior and in order to
change your results living paycheck to
paycheck being stressed out worrying
about your future even your present
circumstances right now
why not focus on working on the neural
patterns the beliefs and habits that are
nothing more than patterns in the brain
that drive 96 to 98 of your behavior and
so she started to work on what i call a
belief and habit modification program
and while she did this she started to
see herself in a different light she
started to feel more confident more
certain and more empowered and what i
can share with you
is she at that moment told me that she
went from making twelve thousand dollars
a year as a widow's from a widow's
pension and living paycheck to paycheck
to being able to charge for her services
as she was making 75 000
a year when you start talking about my
brain
it's an organ it's like your heart is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can
you know speed up the brain waves in
your brain you can slow them down you
can tune in you can tune out yeah we
haven't been given the user's manual for
the most powerful tools we're aware of
that's right
and so the great news you know i know
you being an athlete and a successful
businessman you have discipline you
cannot
i think you can't achieve responsibility
results without some kind of discipline
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and jim rohn is i know you
you love generally so you either pay the
price of discipline or you pay the price
of regret discipline weighs ounces
regret weighs tons that's good but the
the thing is can you teach discipline
the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant
and if the participants reason why
is big enough if they know i want to
achieve x
and the reason why the motive for their
action motivation the motive for their
action
is a reason beyond just themselves
chances are they will do more
to achieve that success than if it was
just left up to their own but there are
some people that are born
you know with incredible drive they just
have this insatiable drive and they'll
just i'll do whatever it takes
for the things that i want and there's
other people that want things but they
just don't have this insatiable drive
and this is where you know i as much as
i hate at school i love to use schools
and analogy yeah in the game of life
whether it's health wealth relationships
career business spirituality fun
experiences you have to decide what
level of the game do i want to play at
is it the great school level the
kindergarten level the high school level
the university level the pro level
because each one of those levels
requires a totally different mindset and
totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a pro business person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude and the talent now
we're talking about there's some real
potential here
and what we don't know is you know
what's in your heart like what is the
fire that stirs you that that you wake
up saying i will do this even when i
don't feel like it i will do whatever it
takes to overcome my temptation for
mediocracy my temptation for excuses my
temptation for
reasons and circumstances to hold me
back i won't allow those to be in my way
and if you have that within you you'll
achieve whatever you choose right and so
the question you asked before is how do
you develop that start small yeah start
small
so if you
don't have discipline show to your show
yourself that you can give yourself one
command and one follow-through so you
know what um right now i'm going to get
up i'm going to do two push-ups
right now not not like later now can you
give yourself a simple command one
sit-up right now i'm going to go get a
glass of water you start with something
ridiculous i learned many years ago
reduce it to the ridiculous
so for reduce it to the ridiculousness i
start i said can you do that
great will you
because that's the difference right
there
is that's the razor's edge the people
who can will you will you yeah great
when
now now yeah right so if you develop
that skill and
specifically from a brain plasticity a
neuroplasticity perspective as soon as
you do that you give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern you can give
yourself a command and take action now
that may just be one time
well what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your computer
and every hour like if you were if my
computer was open i'd have um every hour
it would say it's twelve o'clock it's
one o'clock and i take 60 seconds
just to be in control of my mind
60 i don't care where i stop what you're
doing stop take six breaths just get it
just get centered am i on track am i off
track am i doing something i shouldn't
be doing versus a high impact activity
that i need to be doing
every hour i've trained myself to just
reset
i didn't always do that so i just
started with
one a day right then two sure then three
then it was working so well i said great
let's do this every hour what if
you said okay i want to make let's just
say a hundred thousand dollars a year or
a million it doesn't make a difference
and i asked you
what do you need to believe about
yourself
to achieve this so i need to believe i'm
smart enough good write down i am smart
enough what else do you need to believe
i need to believe that i am worthy i
need to believe that i deserve this i
need to believe that it's possible i
need to believe you write down five or
six or seven beliefs that are just words
on a sheet of paper
now let me stop for just a moment i'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this i want you to imagine
that somebody tapped you
on the shoulder sometime today and say
hey
um i work with steven spielberg and tom
hanks in hollywood and we have this new
script okay that if you get really good
at this script where you could read it
in front of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks
now i want you to imagine you've never
seen the script you don't know how to
act but they said to you we're going to
give you an acting coach we're going to
give you everything you need to memorize
the script we're giving you everything
you need to act it perfectly what would
you do
to take that script that's on a piece of
paper that you've never seen before what
would you do to take that script
to make it yours for you to own it and
the answer is you probably read it like
what once
uh would you read it maybe 100 times 200
times 500 times you think you might
role play with somebody while you're
holding the script in your hand do you
think you might research the role do you
think you might take a camera and
practice it and you think that if you
practice it one time 50 times 100 times
500 times you can finally put the script
down and you can get in front of the
camera and go boom here is the script do
you think you could do that well guess
what a script that's on a piece of paper
that you don't believe with practice you
start to believe so what happens if you
take a belief
system and you start to imprint it into
your subconscious mind initially through
conscious repetition but there are ways
to access the subconscious mind that we
know today that are faster and easier
than just doing it consciously and so
you take a vision of you achieving your
goals and dreams you take the beliefs
you need you learn how to manage your
emotions a little bit better and then
you develop the habits which again are
nothing more than neural patterns in the
brain that have been reinforced and when
you learn how to deactivate the
destructive ones and activate
constructive ones
through space repetition and
reinforcement now you are resetting your
default way of being
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern that if you learn how
to deactivate it and create a new one
it's like a software upgrade for your
brain someone's listening right now and
they're thinking you know there's a lot
of things i want you know i want to get
out of this relationship or i want the
relationship i want to have a better
health i want to have more money
whatever it may be
and they've been saying that for years
and they feel like they've been
consuming all the information they need
to have but they haven't been able to
take action maybe because their why
isn't powerful enough what would you say
should be their first step well the
first step is to take one thing i'm
going to go back to one thing yeah and
say great let me move one thing forward
why because that just changes the
trajectory of the same pattern repeating
itself and as soon as you interrupt a
pattern
and then you repeatedly interrupt the
pattern it's like taking a detour
and as soon as you take a detour one day
you're like okay that was that was okay
but you intended your tendencies to go
back to what's comfortable but if you
take the detour two days six days seven
days we know from a neuroscience
perspective it takes about 66 days to
create a solid enough neural pattern
that it'll go from conscious effort and
thinking about it to a non-conscious
pattern that has the beginnings of
automaticity happening without your
involvement you're just doing yeah and
so
for me what i do and for myself
is i uh whenever i want to change
something whether it's a habit whether
it's a thought or emotion or behavior i
say i'm going to work on this for 100
days not 30 days not 21 days not 66
which is right around there i say 100
days
and then i focus all of my just on that
one thing for 100 days why do you give
an example of something you've done
sugar
sugar sugar
i'm a sugar me too i'm a sugar like if
it was an alcoholic i'm a sugar a whole
pizza right it's so bad so you take one
thing just one thing that you know maybe
a little challenging 100 days 100 days
just 100 days so let's say you want to
drink more water
100 days a glass a day conscious effort
to one a day whatever you did before
you'll still do but one glass a day so
you know i started that with my
assistant so i want to drink you know
like four of these a day you know like
you know 32 ounces whatever the case is
and so every we got a mug and it's on my
desk every time i walk in and then i
have some support from her saying hey
remember to drink your water so just do
it so the first you know two three weeks
i feel like i'm going to drown myself
with so much water
um but then it's like okay now i'm used
to it now i'm drinking as much water as
possible because the habit is there
and one of the rules that i love to
follow is the habit is more important
than the intensity
at first
so don't worry about the intensity right
develop the habit
so can you take one minute a day to
focus on how you will achieve a goal
just one minute a day
can you take one minute a day to focus
on your health yeah can you take one day
to retrain your brain yeah can i take
one day
you know or one action a day right and
you start off with something you know
and reduce it down to just a minute or
two minutes or one behavior if you can
get that behavior to be a habit it's
easy to stack
right of course it's just like the
foundation of a building once you have
the foundation if you build it right you
stack
and so every good discipline affects
another and every bad discipline affects
others when i analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing
and so when we start to focus on
getting the inner game right plus what
you need to do
and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what i want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right
that could buy your product or service
but you don't know how to reach them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling
offering to the marketplace is it
possible that you just don't know how to
reach them
so that means that it's a skill set
issue right
now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like i said earlier where i started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day
online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right um when we
didn't have the internet we had to
advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay
is online offering information content
to develop a relationship and rapport
with prospects and they're taking them
through a process yellow pages that's
right thank you muse debbie debbie muse
right so yellow pages so here's the
thing one of the formulas that you must
figure out is where i started before
traffic times conversion equals revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus
repeat business and referrals equals
exponential revenue
traffic times conversion equals revenue
now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today i'm going to give
you a couple things number one is i need
to adapt i need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them
i want you to ask yourself the question
i posed earlier is what has to happen in
order for me to just double or triple
the leads that i get
leads
the the prospects coming to see you
online or offline if you just focused on
that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and i'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer virginia yeah this
is
this is my new york times best-selling
book the answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a new york times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh let me put that back
over there
on my on my thing um but i didn't come
here to to sell you on my on my book i
want to give you information if anybody
wants to get the book on amazon for 15
or less um it'll blow your mind and the
lux coast you're reading it now awesome
so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover
how do we take our product or service
and create the marketing how many of you
are you good in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning i'm
not talking about branding
i'm talking about getting your product
or service with the right message
in front of the ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay i
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
you need to learn how to manage you need
to learn how to either develop products
you need to learn some of the technology
needs that you have there's a lot of
different hats
that you have to wear
or you have to make sure that somebody
in your company
is wearing that hat right
and so
imagine if you're
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do
you'd have to find how do i get somebody
who could do the surgery so for those of
you who are not good at marketing or
sales which is the oxygen required for
any business regardless of how good your
product or service are
the question you want to be asking
yourself is this who can i hire to help
me
or
who can i barter with to help me
who can i partner with to help me
do my marketing and sales if you're not
good at that so hire
partner
barter
or defer payment to get it done because
without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or
you don't have you're not good at you
don't want it but you still need to
figure out as a business owner how am i
going to get it done your job as a
business owner is not to do everything
but to make sure that everything that is
oxygen and is required gets done
until you learn how to master your
mindset
by recognizing what's holding you back
the real reasons
that you're not taking the actions that
you need to take
and learn how to reframe them in the
right part of your brain so you can
override the messaging signal from the
amygdala the fear center the emotional
center of the brain to the
part of the brain that's responsible for
taking action
you're never going to achieve your goals
so whether you have doubts or fears or
anxieties fear of success fear of
failure if you're losing your job if
you're losing your home if you're losing
your money
you have to understand that just like
a car
has a light that pops up on the
dashboard when something's wrong in the
engine
you have an emotion that is your signal
to let you know whether you're feeling
good or not whether you're comfortable
or not whether you have certainty or not
whether you have confidence or not and
if you're lacking the confidence and the
certainty it's going to cause doubt if
you're going to have doubt it may cause
anxiety
and as soon as that sets into the brain
in a nanosecond
your ability to take action
is like having one foot on the gas and
one foot on the brake
there's going to be a lot of movement
going on the tires but you're really not
going to get anywhere
so the first thing i want you to do
is write down what's really holding you
back
why aren't you really get clear get deep
why aren't you really taking action
towards any of your goals health goals
financial goals business goals whatever
goals you have
write that down
and ask yourself
is this real is this imagined is it a
probability or is it a possibility what
you'll find
for the most part is the negative
consequence
is a possibility and as soon as you buy
into that possibility
you're going to do everything possible
to run away to fight freeze or fight
that feeling
but when you learn how to switch your
brain from recognizing what's holding
you back
to reframing the possibility to
do it from the probability to just a
normal possibility
you start to activate
different parts of your brain that
starts showing you the solutions
to how to overcome the fear how to
overcome the risk how to overcome the
possible negative consequence and then
what happens is the amygdala the part of
your brain that's responsible to protect
you and keep you safe
the firing threshold of that signal gets
lowered
the message to the motor cortex doesn't
get sent so you start to take action
and third what is happening
is that your left prefrontal cortex the
ceo the genius part of your brain
starts to think about ways that you can
actually take action and do it faster
and easier and better
it starts to change what you see start
to change your vibration and now you
start to have a lot more control
over not just having goals and having
strategies and plans but getting
yourself to take action if we have
constructive positive empowering beliefs
we move forward and take action but when
we have a limiting belief like i'm not
good enough i'm not smart enough i'm not
worthy i'm not skilled i'm too young i'm
too old i'm too white i'm too black i'm
too asian caucasian i'm this or i'm that
i'm not enough of this i'm not enough of
that
where are our beliefs
right we have two types of beliefs we
have conscious beliefs that we can
declare and then we have subconscious
beliefs as well which ones are the more
powerful of the two
mike edwards says subconscious beliefs
right
mike
says subconscious beliefs were you born
with any beliefs like if you were a
neuroanatomist
okay if you're a neuroanatomist if you
were to look in the brain
where would you find your beliefs the
positive the negative ones the good ones
the challenging ones the constructive
destroy where would you find them
what are they like what are they
right like what are they
aren't those patterns
that have been reinforced based on what
we learned in childhood aren't those
patterns that our parents gave us our
teachers our brothers our sisters our
neighbors
right didn't we
develop our beliefs
through the imprinting years zero to
five or six the modeling years five or
six to you know seven or eight and then
the um the um um
experiential years
right all the way from birth to 25 26
when our brain was pretty plastic and we
developed these beliefs about
what to believe we weren't born with any
they're nothing more than neural
patterns in the brain now how many of
you have heard the word
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity right what is
neuroplasticity
neuroplasticity
is the scientific fact that our brain
is plastic
right what does that mean it's not like
plastic like this brain
it means that we have brain cells
right so the brain cells okay there's a
cell
there's an axon okay or a body then
there's dendrites at the end right and
there's synaptic gaps in between the
brain cells so those brains have
potentiality and let's say we are told
that you're not good enough you're not
smart enough you're not worthy you'll
never amount to much you're too young
you're too old you don't have enough
knowledge you don't have enough skill if
those patterns are created and those
neurons are active and releasing those
neural chemicals from a receptor or from
a
ascending neuron to a receptor neuron
and that happens often enough that
neuron structure or pathway
becomes more solid just like
developing a highway system in a city
and the pathways that are active and
reinforced when we are young
become the default pathways just like
the highways and the roads that you take
every single day to go to the stores you
take
now if it's true that our neural
pathways are not fixed but the pathways
that are easy to run across okay or to
fire the signals okay are the ones that
are dominant
is it possible
to let go of the limiting destructive
disempowering beliefs
that somebody else gave us for the most
part or we experienced
is it possible that through
conditioning programming deliberately
choosing our beliefs
and reinforcing new neural pathways we
can
create new neural pathways
right
so
if a neural pathway can be created and
neural pathways can be deactivated
then why not deliberately unconsciously
evolve yourself
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see my last one-on-one with the
amazing john astrav check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there well we all own the most
powerful biocomputer in the world in the
universe and most people don't know how
to change their brain to change their
income